Mohamed el-erian is an influential voice
in the financial world
he led PIMCO for years running the
world's largest bond fund now he's the
chief economic adviser at Allianz and he
says the economy could look very
different as we emerge from the pandemic
I sat down with him on Friday
mr. el-erian new unemployment numbers
came in this week just under 3 million
and White House economic advisor Kevin
Hassett said while that is a tough
number it's an indication that the
economy is starting to come back here he
is I think the fact that we came in
under 3 million suggests that the
turning on of the economy is beginning
and it's beginning to show up with the
data so what we expect now is that
claims will continue to decline as the
economy turns back do you see the jobs
picture getting brighter right now so it
will get brighter in the sense that will
get bad at a slower rate but we should
not forget how bad this picture is with
the additional 3 million Chris that is
36 million people have signed up for on
topless claims for in 8 weeks that's one
quarter of our labor force so it's an
enormous shock so the consistent
forecasts from the White House is of a
sharp steep quick downturn to be
followed in a v-shape by a sharp quick
rebound here is President Trump or not
this week we're gonna do well in the
fourth quarter and I think next year
with all of the stimulus orders and
things we've done I think we're gonna
have one of the best economic years
we've ever had
do you see a v-shaped recovery as the
White House is predicting that the
economy is gonna come back as quickly
and as sharply as it went down I sure
hope so but I think it's uncertain and
it's uncertain because both the journey
to next year and what next year look
like are uncertain
so rather than think of letters think of
a pendulum Chris we were operating in a
normal world as you and I defined it
we then swung all the way on the other
side to a lockdown and now we're gonna
swing back and forth trying to find
where the new equilibrium is so it's not
gonna be a neat Vee it's gonna be more
like a series of w's if you like but
think of a pendulum swinging and we
don't know the magnitude of the swings
and we don't know the duration of the
swing or the settling point so it really
is an uncertain outlook I want to pick
up on that because you say people are
being naive about how easy it and quick
it is gonna be to reopen the economy
that we have to deal with health factors
and economic factors and even behavioral
factors explain what you mean both in
terms of this country and globally in
reopening the economy so this is the
biggest shock we've had for generations
and it weighs it's we issue one is the
main reason for the shock is health and
there's gonna be a long time until you
and I trust each other
it's what Eric Schmidt calls the
information failure it's very difficult
for me to convince you I'm healthy and
for you to convince me I'm healthy till
we get a vaccine so the health issue
doesn't get resolved overnight secondly
you have shaken consumer confidence you
have shaken behaviors our economy isn't
wired for social distancing so we're
gonna have to discover how to do that
and third businesses it's not clear how
you we start a business when different
states are doing different things and
when different countries are going to do
different things so we have these three
massive uncertainties all in play at the
same time and it's very hard to say oh
everything's gonna be resolved overnight
we hope so but I think we should buckle
our seat belt that is gonna get bumpy
still well there's another uncertainty
and debate and that is over what to do
in Washington next Democrats won a three
trillion dollar another huge stimulus
bill Republicans say let's take a pause
and see how the money siphons through
the
economy that's been approved so far and
this week you had Federal Reserve
Chairman Jerome Powell say that this has
been a real economic shock and we do
need more stimulus here he is on that
well the economic response has been both
timely and appropriately large it may
not be the final chapter given that the
path ahead is both highly uncertain and
subject to significant downside risks do
you think we need more government
stimulus and if so how much and how
quickly
so so far Chris we haven't had
government stimulus we've had government
relief and it's a good thing we've had
it and it's a good thing that Washington
reacted five trillion dollars worth of
reaction because despite that this week
also gave us not just a horrible
unemployment number but the worst
industrial output collapse in a century
and the worst retail sale collapse on
record so so we are hurting and thank
God that Washington has reacted on the
relief measures what's important now is
not to lose sight that there's a second
phase this is not just about winning the
war against a global depression and a
u.s. depression this is about securing
the peace about making sure that we
emerge from this also strong so the next
stage has to also focus on key issues
like infrastructure labor retailing and
retooling safety nets things that are
going to be critical if we are to bounce
back in a sustainable manner otherwise
we're gonna get stuck in a new normal of
really mediocre growth and greater
social tensions and then there are the
financial markets which I think have
surprised a lot of people by remaining
surprisingly strong in fact the markets
are up about 25 percent from their
bottom in late March you say that the
financial markets are in one universe
and the real economy is in a different
universe what do you mean they're
looking at different things so you and I
and the real economy are wondering when
do we get to go back to
when other stores open again we feel
very big disruptions long everyday life
the marketplace are saying look that's
fine but that's all short-term we look
to the long-term and when they look to
the long-term they see a win-win
hypothesis I think they're too
optimistic but let me explain what they
see first a bet that we're going to come
back quickly the V and if we come back
quickly then looking through which is
the phrase our hero most this awful
period is the right thing to do but they
have a second win Chris if we get that
wrong it doesn't matter because the
Federal Reserve is buying assets and is
buying assets with that we never
imagined it could buy so there's this
sense of comfort that you get to win
whatever the outlook I think Chris that
it's too optimistic but markets do what
they do well I was gonna ask you who do
you think the markets as one of the
great investors do you think the markets
are gonna say stay as strong as they are
right now or do you think at some point
the two universes are gonna collide and
reality will intrude so most of us who
think fundamentals are important that
ultimately you are betting on company's
profitability and you're betting on the
viability of a system or courses here
and we've had several warnings from
really respected investors but I also
understand those who say that's fine but
you are dinosaurs we are betting on
something different we are betting on
the Federal Reserve and if you have a
printing press in the basement then you
can have a massive influence on markets
I personally think it's easier to make a
relative call between different
companies
I get nervous betting on the overall
level of the market right here Mohamed
el-erian thank you so much
it is always fascinating to talk to you
and to get a little dose of reality
thanks so much sir thank you Chris